hey guys I'm here in studio with Dave
Ramsey to celebrate a huge milestone we
hit over the weekend 1 million
subscribers on YouTube is that not crazy
a million a million subscribers a
million of anything is like a lot I
can't count that house a lot George yeah
and we started this thing six years ago
and you remember I mean it was just a
little baby thing and we thought okay
we'll try out this YouTube here to be
cute to be on YouTube it'd be kind of
cute now it's a monster we're hitting 20
million guys are awesome thank you
20 million monthly views people are
connecting to this stuff and you know
you've done radio now for 30 years now
yeah and I don't think I've done 20
million anything that's pretty crazy
yeah I mean it's it's nuts you know with
YouTube now with the 20 million views
and with the downloads on the podcast
and the mainstream radio all of it
together is well over my goodness that
that's what up to 40 million now
goodness gracious and it's crazy that
this digital space we can impact so many
more people than we used to be able to
now with all this podcasts and YouTube
and you don't want one of the best
things about the YouTube is it the
audience is shifting and because I'm
getting 20 and 21 years old and 22 years
old I never used to get that before I
mean YouTube but where most of y'all are
coming from we know where you're coming
from it's pretty incredible and I gotta
say we're probably one of the more
productive hopeful channels on YouTube
you know of all the videos on there
we're trying to bring some hope to the
gorge there's some snarky people out
there not our fans thank you all so much
1 million subscribers what an
achievement thank you all